hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast fine tuning of myosin
activity shapes actual myosin Network
organization and tissue contractility of
the c elegans spermatheca
presented by alison Wersching graduate
student at north north eastern
university i am marjorie torus of lab
reads and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labrys labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Alison Wersching I will now turn the
presentation over to Anna hello good
morning everyone and thank you Marjorie
for that lovely introduction so again my
name is Alison Wersching and I am a
graduate student at the crime lab at
Northeastern University and what we're
interested in the crime lab is how to
contract pound on muscle cells perceive
and appropriately respond to mechanical
stimuli for example in humans there are
smooth muscle cells that surround the
cardiovascular system and myoepithelial
cells that surround glands in the
vasculature system smooth muscle cells
must be able to proceed
proprietary respond to changes in the
luminol pressure in order to maintain
tube diameter
similarly in gland cells myoepithelial
cells must be able to perceive when the
glands are full and then contract to
expel gland contents one of the ways we
know that cells respond to mechanical
stimuli is by reorganizing their actin
cytoskeleton so here you can see an
example of confluence cells together
upon the application of shear stress now
there are production of these parallel
optimized bundles or stress fibers that
help the cells withstand stress
similarly if you pull on two attached
cells McKenna perceptive proteins will
recruit sinus alpha skeletal components
and reinforce those junctions the actin
cytoskeleton is also reorganized under
different conditions here I'm showing
you an example of asthma experiment
where they took long tail epithelial
cells and expose them to dust my
irritation and now which you see is
especially if you look right there in
the center of cells they have begun to
become very contractile and produce
those optimized and bundles so how is it
that actin and myosin is able to
generate forces within cells to
withstand external forces this is
accomplished through myosin motor
activity on actin filaments so here in
this cartoon I'm showing you myosin and
green and actin and red and what that
looks like at the molecular level is
here shown at the bottom so in non
muscle cells myosin activity is really
tightly regulated by phosphorylation
when the myosin regulatory light chain
is not phosphorylated such as is shown
here it is kept in this inactive
conformation
it cannot interact with actin and it
cannot produce force however upon
phosphorylation it now adopts this
active conformation conformed by polar
filaments which then pull on actin and
slide actin and produce forces
so that is how myosin activity on
contractility is regulated at the
molecular level however in addition to
in addition to the level of phospho or
act of myosin we also have actin myosin
Network organization really impacting
tissue and cell contractility so now if
we zoom out and think of actin myosin as
an entire network you can appreciate the
actin Network orientation as well as
connectivity can influence contractility
so here my active network is not very
well oriented and now I'm going to get
sort of a global uniform contraction
however if I have a very aligned Network
I'm going to predominantly get orient
its
contraction in one direction if on the
other hand I think about connectivity if
I have a very not very connected Network
I'm going to get small local
contractions you can imagine if I cut
the rope that those green men are
pulling on instead if I have a very
connected network now I can get global
contractions across an entire cell and
across entire tissues and so the system
we use to study how cells are able to
regulate their amount of active or
fausto myosin and their actin
organization in order to appropriately
maintain tissue contract Tilly is c
elegans reproductive system so the C
elegans reproductive system is basically
one long contractile - that is composed
of two u-shaped gonad arms
shown here and here
that come together and to a common
uterus in the center of the animal so
during the reproductive life of the
animal the oocytes develop in the distal
gonad which is shown here as they come
around the bend that's showing the net
yellow loop they mature and then once
they aren't ready sheep cell
contractions the tissue shown in yellow
push
I'm a sight into the spermatheca the
sperm if you get is stretched the embryo
becomes fertilized and that is expelled
into the uterus and so here's just a
zoomed in picture of what that looks
like where the spermatheca shown is
green the sheath cells that surround the
oocyte and contract to push the OSI in
spermatheca is shown in yellow and the
uterus is shown in red so specifically
the part of the system that we're really
interested in and that we use as our
model is the spermatheca which is a
saclink organ of 24 Mile epithelial
cells that houses the sperm and is the
site of fertilization we like to use the
sperm at vika for a few reasons one it
has discrete and predictable events of
being relaxed of being stretched by the
incoming site and then producing
coordinated contractions after
fertilization so all of our stretch and
contraption experiments happen in vivo
without us having to manipulate the
system additionally this has to happen
150 times per spare motika meaning the
system must be very robust and all of
this is easily visualized in live
animals and so to give you a feel of
what that looks like i'm going to show
you a movie of an ovulation
so this go site here you can see is
outlined with a dotted line is going to
be pushed by the sheath cells 17 turning
yellow into spermatheca it will become
fertilized and then spermatheca
contractions will push back in embryo
into the uterus so we'll watch that now
all right pushed into the sperm Deepika
it's becoming fertilized and now exiting
through the sperm making you to rappel
into the uterus so I've been saying that
during this process the spermatheca
becomes dramatically stretched and then
has to contract and so maybe that is
easier to see if you look at what the
cell outlines actually look like so in
an unoccupied spermatheca
that does not contain the O site you can
see this cells look very relaxed sort of
compressed and then once the OSI enters
the cells become really stretched out
and so what we're interested in is what
does the actin cytoskeleton look like in
this process and how does it contribute
to tissue robustness and contractility
so to address those
first set out to say okay what is the
act and that would look like on the top
here I'm showing you a cartoon and I'm
showing this because one of the things
that's really nice about studying this
system is that each cell in each
spermatheca develops the same way in
each animal so they always have the same
24 cells and those cells always have the
same neighbors and in this cartoon up
here which you can see as the arrows in
each cell indicate the alignment of the
actin Network so it's very stereotyped
it's the same across every animal and
what you can see is that the actin
Network becomes aligned along the long
axis of each cell interestingly the
these parallel actin fibers are also
present even unoccupied spermatheca so
although they're probably easier to see
here in the occupied spermatheca that's
because the cells have been stretched
out it's not because they're not absent
any longer when this permit because no
longer occupied and then if we look here
at a cross-section you can see in blue I
have false colored the sperm and then in
here in pink
I have false colored the oocyte just to
show you what it looks like when it's
stretched out and you can also see if
you look carefully but these bundles
these actin bundles that I've been
talking about are at the basal cell
layer okay so now you know what actin
looks like end of story
except previous graduate student is
where I made this really interesting
observation that in young animals these
actin bundles that are parallel that
I've been talking about our absent so
our question was alright what is
happening how is it that these actin
bundles are forming is this something
that happens as part of development such
that as the animal matures and prepares
to undergo these stretch and contraction
events the actin cytoskeleton develops
or is that actually that's something
about ovulation something about
stretching themselves and having them
contract is that causes the active
network to go from something that's very
webby and isotropic and not organized
shown here maybe clearest if you look at
that one cell to an actin Network which
is highly organized and has nice
parallel fibers again letting along the
long axis of each cell
so to address this question we used two
different techniques to disrupt a site
entry in order to uncouple animal age so
is it just a maturing from actually an
ovulation event where you have stretch
and contraction leading to these fibers
and so to do this we either genetically
blocked osai entry by disrupting a gene
required for the production of a site
the other technique we used was to block
cheek cell function therefore there are
no sheep contractions to push that I was
like into the spermatheca and when I
hope you can appreciate is that in all
cases compared to the control organized
actin cytoskeleton if we disrupt the
site entry so if we block ovulation we
never develop those nice parallel
organized fibers you can see that
another way across many animals if we
quantify and I saw Tippi which is just a
measure of how oriented the network is
and so here you can see that regardless
of animal age they never develop
organized fibers if you block out site
entry so to answer the question no it's
not just something to do with
development actually ovulation is
required to go from a disorganized
network to an organized network so what
actually happens during ovulation a lot
of things and work from our lab and
others has really gone into
understanding what are the pathways
involved in perceiving some stretch and
regulating sperm if you could
contractility and here I'm just
highlighting some recent work from our
lab and I know this is a lot of
information but really what I want you
to take home from this is that all of
the key players are highly conserved so
both calcium signaling and ro signaling
are conserved in C elegans and mammals
and in your favorite contractile cells
this isn't just some weird thing that
happens worms it's very highly conserved
concerned but instead of going over all
the details of my glorious pathway and
when instead just gonna show you the
simplified one because they don't have
time to talk about every member and here
I'm just going to bring up the key
players that will be important in this
talk so as I mentioned earlier we have
the calcium side of the pathway and the
ROS side of the pathway so phospholipase
c shown here at the top
it was responsible for calcium
production which then through its
interaction with calmodulin increases
myosin activity through activating the
myosin light-chain kinase more kinase
activity allows for more fosfomycin and
more contraction on the other side we
have the Rho pathway so Rho becomes
activated by cell stretch which then
activates Rho kinase which then
deactivates the off switch
- and phosphatase so without myosin
phosphatase we again have an increase in
active boss of myosin and increased
contractility so in this way cell
stretch through two sides of the pathway
one regulating on switch one regulating
off switch leads to increased
contraction and so one of the ways we've
been able to study this is by
visualizing calcium and EVO so here I'm
going to show you a video and in this
movie what you'll see are the cell
outlines of the spermatheca in red and
calcium in green use a genetically
encoded calcium biosensor gcamp so an
increase in fluorescence intensity
increase indicates an increase in
calcium so now the site is entering the
spermatheca
now the cells have become stretched out
and you can see those big calcium waves
going back and forth across the tissue
and if we measure calcium intensity or
fluorescence intensity over time which
you can see over this 50-minute time is
that it's very stable and doesn't change
at all except during ovulation
so once the cells become stretched out
and produce a contraction that's when
you have that peak of calcium so really
it seems that calcium is very tightly
regulated and as important for
contraction so what we know up to this
point is that the spermatheca becomes
highly stretched during ovulation we
also know that during ovulation we have
production of calcium transients that
really peak at the onset of contraction
and we know that something about either
cell stretch or calcium signaling or
something to be with ovulation is
required to go from this disorganized
isotropic Network seen in young animals
Joonas highly organized very parallel
active network you see many mature
adults
so now our questions are when exactly
during ovulation business Koerner and
what is the molecular mechanism driving
this organization and so it became clear
that in order to address these questions
we needed higher temporal resolutions we
needed to be able to see what's
happening in real time
and so to answer this we turn to in vivo
imaging so what I'm going to show you
here is it would be much like the one
you saw earlier except now I'm using
tissue specific promoter driving GFP
labeled actin so the only tissue you're
going to see is the spermatheca and
although you can't see it there is a
proximal a site that is ready to be
fertilized right here and what's going
to happen are sheets all contractions
are then going to push the OA site into
the spermatheca the spermatheca will
become stretched out by the O site and
then dramatic actin reorganization is
going to take place okay so alright and
stretched and now contraption is
happening now you can really see those
beautiful fibers that I was talking
about earlier and we're very clear now
we're gonna play that one more time and
what I want you to try to see this time
is the difference now immediately after
entry and then at the end of the movie
that's going to be important on the next
slide okay so I briefly mentioned this
earlier we have this tool called liberal
tool which we are able to use to measure
the organization of the active network
in individual cells so here I'm just
showing you about what an experiment
might look like so I would take a movie
and then shown in yellow an outline an
individual cell and then measure the
increase in actin organization over time
and so what you can see is that early on
we have very low organization very
isotropic not organized network and then
later on it becomes organized and so
then down here at the bottom of your
slide I'm just showing
stills from that movie so here's the
first frame immediately after OSI entry
I have a Webby isotropic Network much
like the network that I saw in the young
animals that had never operated however
after a while I now see those beautiful
parallel bundles that I have been
talking about okay and so the nice thing
about federal tool and being able to
visualize this in vivo is we're really
able to tease out when is this
organization occurring and so by
measuring cell length as a metric for
cell contraction so as the cell
contracts it shrinks in length I am able
to determine when is contraction
occurring and using several tool I'm
able to say when is the increase in
actin organization occurring and what
you can see is as there is an onset in
contraction so as the sawing increases
that's when I start to have an increase
in actin organization and shown another
way if I look at the slope of the line
for the increase organization you can
see that really Peaks right as the cell
begins to contract so now you know that
this organization requires ovulation so
the OA site has to enter and stretch out
the sperm at nikka but are really cool
incised with contraction so it isn't
just the cell stretch alone is enough to
take this isotropic network and stretch
it out in alignment it's something about
the onset of contraction appears to be
important we're also able to use this
tool called orientation J to look at how
the actin cytoskeleton becomes oriented
within each cell so orientation J is
used to colored fibers according to
their orientation and what you can see
here are warm colors indicate that 90
degrees and cold colors are about zero
degrees so horizontal and not only our
parallel fibers produced but they are
always oriented on the long cell access
such that cells which are horizontal
such as this one you can see right here
in the front have a blue color whereas
other cells which are oriented
vertically you have a red color and
again this occurs the same way in every
animal always okay so now I think we
have the answer to our first question
which is when during ovulation does this
organization occur
and it really appears to coincide the
contraction so that our next question is
what drives the production of these
bundles and what controls their
alignment and so sort of our first hint
at what might be happening here in
addition to the timing is that we
observed that there was a difference in
actin organization between minimally
stretched and matched maximally stressed
spermatheca so sometimes during the
first ovulation instead of the entire
O's like getting in there only a small
fraction gets in I'm showing you an
example of that at the top here so you
can see this spermatheca appears smaller
because a smaller piece of the OS I
entered and in that case the actin
Network let's go undergo some changes
but does not become as organized as the
spermatheca here which appears larger
because a larger oocytes stretched it
out so and you can see this graphed here
across multiple animals is that there's
a correlation between the spermatheca
which were stretched more and those that
became more organized and so our
hypothesis for this is that something
about cell stretch is actually
increasing contractility so cell stretch
itself isn't responsible for aligning
the network but is perhaps modulating
the amount of active myosin and
therefore the amount of contraction one
explanation for this is that there is a
Meccano perceptive grow gap SP v1 which
has been identified by the zidle bar lab
one of our collaborators this row gap is
able to perceive membrane curvature
shown here such that when the
spermatheca is unoccupied and then that
really shrunken conformation the
membrane is very curvy and so this gap
stays there but then upon ovulation when
the other side enters in the spermatic
it becomes very stretched out the ro gap
is removed from the membrane and you
have increased contraction so the
takeaway from this is we know there's at
least one mechanism where cell stretch
can lead to increased contraction so
another way to more directly impact
contraction to try to uncouple so
stretched from actual contraction is
through taking advantage of what we know
plc one does so plc one is the
phospholipase c he responsible for
calcium production which increases
like chain kinase activity leading to
increased mice and activation so if we
get rid of PLC 1 we don't have any
calcium transients produced
additionally we shouldn't have any cell
contraction and so now I'm going to show
you an ovulation video of a PLC 1ml
animal this is much like the video that
I showed you earlier except now there
won't be any calcium produced and so now
we get to see what happens to act an
organization in the absence of calcium
so now although we had entry don't
really have production of those parallel
fibers it sort of just sits there and
Wiggles around but does not become
organized like we saw earlier ok so our
hypothesis has been that plc one
produces calcium that calcium then reads
interaction with calmodulin activates
myosin light-chain kinase this increases
the amount of fosfomycin and that
something about active myosin is
important for producing these organized
bundles
however to be honest this is really a
very simplified view of all of the
things that calcium does within a cell
so it's possible that in addition to
influencing the amount of active myosin
calcium could have some other important
interactors and so to really test ok is
this something specific to the amount of
active myosin or is this something else
that calcium is activating returned
again to our knowledge penpals from
Ithaca contractility is regulated and
looked at what happens if we get rid of
the myosin phosphatase so now we would
hypothesize that in the absence of plc
one we would have depressed activity of
the calcium side of the pathway right so
we don't have calcium production so we
should not have as much myosin
light-chain kinase activity however if
you get rid of the off switch the myosin
phosphatase you now would be able to
unmask appeal C one independent pool of
active myosin and therefore increase the
amount of active myosin present and
hopefully if we're correct rescue
production of actin bundles and so we
did just that experiment to see what
would happen okay so in the top here I'm
going to show you the wild-type movie
that I showed you before where we saw
action organization coinciding with
and on the bottom here I'm going to show
you the PLC one null animal that I
showed you before this animal does not
produce calcium transients and will not
contract so the active network will stay
very isotropic and disorganized and here
in the center what we've done is in the
plc one no an animal that lacks calcium
signaling we also knocked down the
myosin phosphatase so now any amount of
active myosin that's present will be
able to stay active and we should
increase the overall amount of active
myosin and potentially be able to rescue
parallel bundle production so let's
watch and see what happens I mean you
can see sure enough this animal
definitely has more active Maya than the
animal at the bottom and definitely has
rescue of parallel actin bundles
I've quantified here on this graph you
can see wild-type at the top is the most
organized whereas the out of calcium
signaling at the bottom shown in green
there is really no organization
occurring and then I do get a slight
rescue if I knock down the myosin
phosphatase I increase the amount of
active myosin and I do see rescue of my
active network organization okay so now
we have the answer to our first question
this dramatic change and act the
organization really coincides with
contraction and unsurprisingly giving
when it happens
this requires myosin activity so myosin
really appears to be driving actin
bundle production however we did make
another observation based on this data
here and that is that while we do have
an increase in bundle production as you
can see the rescue isn't perfect so this
orange line here is nowhere near as
organized as the wild-type line here
shown in purple and yes it could be true
that we don't have the same amount of
active myosin however we are also not
necessarily recapitulating the wild-type
spatial-temporal activation of myosin so
it might be important not just how much
active myosin is present but exactly
when during stretch and contraction do
you have peak levels of myosin activity
so looking at this further we notice
that in addition to not being as organ
what we really noticed is that there was
a failure to produce the alignment along
the long cell axis so again I'm showing
your data using orientation j and in the
top here all of my fibers from a single
cell are oriented in the same direction
so they're all the same color oriented
about 90 degrees vertical all red colors
however in the same cell but in a
different animal this animal now is the
PLC one no that has been treated with
mel 11 RNA i to increase the amount of
fosfomycin i can see yes in fact there
are very clear bundles produced but
they're no longer perfectly oriented
along the long cell access and i have
populations of differently oriented
bundles all right so myosin activity is
required for bundle production but
something about the proper activation of
myosin is important to producing the
stereotyped organized Network
alright back to the slide so in order to
more directly probe what the role of
myosin activity is on actin Network
alignment we used a few different
techniques so instead of disrupting
calcium we really wanted to hammer how
much active myosin that there is so we
did this in two ways one we either got
rid of the myosin light-chain kinase so
that should really depress myosin
activity and keep myosin in this
inactive conformation can't interact
with actin and can't produce
contractions we also got rid of the
myosin heavy chain itself so no myosin
present at all and then the other thing
we did to really ramp up my selectivity
to see what happens if we go in the
other direction and have highly elevated
mice neck giving what happens to actin
organization and bundle alignment and so
to accomplish that we got rid of the off
switch our myosin phosphatase in the
absence of myosin phosphatase any myosin
that becomes phosphorylated and active
stays that way so you just increase and
increase and increase and constitutive
lis contract ok so let's see what that
looks like what I'm showing you here in
red and in green our results from
phalloidin staining so that's cut and
fixed animals and then our in vivo
marker is in green and I'm just showing
you both of these to demonstrate that
everything we've observed we can observe
in multiple ways and it
just that our active labels aren't
influencing the experiment outcome so on
the top here are control animals and as
I've been saying all along you can see
that there are parallel actin bundles
present in the and they're oriented
along the long cell axes in each case
and then if I get rid of myosin entirely
I have this really flaccid spermatheca
you can see the valve showing here in
both cases really stays open and and
flaccid it's not able to close at all
and if you look carefully at the actin
structures they remain very tortuous and
webby and resemble the actin
organization and the young animals that
had never undergone an ovulation even
though these are all the animals of the
sperm Anika has become stretched out so
really in the absence of myosin we don't
get any organization of the active
network really demonstrating that myosin
is important okay and so then there is
kind of the fun part
now if we get rid of the off switch the
myosin phosphatase and really constitute
a increase contraction we get this crazy
phenotype where we now have really huge
prominent actor myosin bundles and
what's interesting to me is that in
addition to production of really large
bundles you can see that these bundles
get pulled in two different orientations
so there's a nice example there this
sort of gave us insight into how it
might be that myosin activity is
important for regulating the alignment
along the long cell access all right so
throughout this talk I've been talking a
lot about actin and myosin but primarily
just showing you what actin looks like
and we're really interested in what does
mice look like in this network as well
how is my son organized and as from
Antigua and so to the answer to that
question we looked at both actin and
myosin in animals so here I'm showing
you actin in red and myosin in green and
again at the top is a control animal and
what you can see are those beautiful
parallel fibers running along the long
axis of each cell that you've seen the
whole time and then if we use a line
scan and look at fluorescence intensity
which you can see is everywhere there is
a peak in actin indicating an active
fiber there's also a peak in myosin so
these are really tightly associated into
these acta mize and bundles additionally
you can see that the
aren't really any differences in actinic
email in my as an accumulation along the
fibers in other words myosin is
homogeneously distributed throughout
optimized and bundles it doesn't seem to
accumulate anywhere alright so what
happens if we get rid of the myosin
light-chain kinase so now we really
depressed myosin activity well
unsurprisingly - and now remains largely
cytosol like so you can see that through
a line scan you can see that now where
there's a peak in actin there's no
longer a peak in myosin so this makes
sense to us because without
phosphorylation myosin stays in that
closed off conformation it's not able to
form filaments and interact with actin
so now it just stays in the cytosol
floating around isn't helpful so the
next thing we wanted to look at is what
happens if we go the other way and we
really increase the amount of act niacin
well I had a hypothesis and what I had
imagined is that we would get a case
that looks much like this top graph here
except perhaps we would have larger
Peaks in green indicating hyper
recruitment of myosin into these ACTA
myosin bundles much to our surprise
however we got this which is totally
unexpected for us so instead of having
increased myosin recruitment to these
bundles homogeneous throughout the
bundles we now have these really light
really bright foci being formed so if
you look here you can see that there is
this band of myosin that forms and also
appears to be connected across multiple
parallel actin actin bundles so this was
very intriguing to us we wanted to
understand how is this for me how is it
that actin how is it that myosin goes
from presumably something that looks
like this top animal here where it's
homogeneously distributed throughout to
then when you really increase my as an
activity forming these bright myosin
foci that are also interestingly aligned
across multiple actin bundles suggesting
potentially that myosin is interacting
across bundles and to answer that quest
we turned to invivo visualization of
this so this again is an ovulation would
be much like the ones I've shown you
earlier now I'm showing you myosin in
green acted in red and we're active in
myosin clockwise you'll see yellow so
the top is going to be a wild type movie
and the bottom is what's going to be
happen if I get rid of them 11:11 again
is the myosin phosphatase or the off
switch so in the top movie the OSI is
going to enter stretch out the
spermatheca
spur media contractions are then going
to culminate in exit of the then
fertilized embryo into the uterus this
is all going to happen quite fast I've
sped it up so that the bottom movie
plays are more reasonable great so
what's gonna happen at the bottom movie
is that after OSI entry the valve is not
able to open and the embryo becomes
trapped so because I've gotten rid of
the off switch the phosphatase and now
have constitutive contraction so the
tissues going to continue to contract
the contract and contract and we'll be
able to watch what happens to my as an
organization throughout this process so
again talking the entry culmination
contraction and exit the sperm it goes
back at that closed conformation and
they'll crazy things are happening on
the bottom but I will explain what okay
I didn't prepare you alright so nothing
look quite good but you were gonna watch
it again on the top we have entry we
have initiation of active myosin and
contraction and both through the rope a
pre and you the calcium pathway this
leads to mice and recruitment into ACTA
mice and bundles pulling on those
bundles and then exit because the tissue
contracts
however on the bottom it's unable to
exit the embryo the reason it's unable
to exit is because the valve stays
really tightly closed so as contractions
increase and increase and increase
instead of the valve nicely opening what
actually happens is these basal actin
bundles pull apart and the tissue
actually rips at the cell junctions
break and now the embryo is released
into the body cavity of the animal which
is not where it's supposed to be okay so
now if we watch that bottom video again
you can see at the basal surface there
it really starts to pull back right
about
Oh yep and now the whole thing is gonna
split open like that okay so those
movies play a little bit fast and maybe
it's easier to see what's going on if we
look at individual still frames so at
the top here I'm showing you what a wild
type movie looks like the same one I
showed you on a previous slide and which
you can see is initially myosin is
largely cytosolic and you can just see
some actin fibers but it really just
looks like a great haze and the reason
for that is because until contraction is
initiated myosin isn't a cytosol it's
not pulling on the fibers and then once
contraction is initiated it's sort of
hard to see actin network organization
because the tation really rapidly
contracts as the acai is pushed out or
the embryo I should say is pushed out
into the uterus however on the bottom
now I've gotten rid of a myosin
phosphatase so now I have constitutive
contraction and what you can see here is
initially it looks much like the top the
top frame where I have actin fibers and
largely cytosol of myosin however even
just three minutes and 20 seconds into
the movie if you look very carefully you
can start to see small mice and foci
along the actin fiber and these foci
really increase in intensity over time
so here just a few minutes later you can
see that they're much brighter and much
more prominent additionally you can see
is they start to align so if you have
multiple foci as they come close to each
other they align together so it looks
like that mice and foci on parallel
fibers are actually somehow able to
interact with one another such they
become aligned across multiple bundles
we were also really fortunate in this
movie capable unable to catch another
cool thing whereas in this case here
those two actin fibers or actin bundles
have just retracted backwards and
they're able to wrap retract up until
reaching it's a lot of arrows a band of
myosin shown there so it really looks
like mice and again is interacting with
other mice and both I on parallel actin
bundles such that these two fibers that
are able to retract but then stop once
they reach this continuous band of
myosin and this process continues all
the way up until this basal layer pulls
all the way back as the fibers really
increase in cotton and contractility and
then as we saw in the movie this finally
Coleman
and such intense contractions that the
tissue rips apart and the embryo is just
released into the body cavity of the
animal it is perhaps easier to see how
these my suppose I are coming together
if we look at a kymograph so on the
bottom panel here I'm showing you kinda
graphs from four different cells across
four different ovulation movies and
let's just pick an example so if you
look right here what you can see is that
at the beginning of this movie so time
is along the bottom access the yellow is
very homogeneous meaning that there is
both red and green present in this cell
and then as the movie plays you can see
right where I put the arrow I have these
two minus and bands that then sort of
come together and so that is why the
myosin my suppose I appear to be coming
brighter and a-line as we play this
movie throughout time okay so in
conclusion what I've shown you today is
that calcium signaling is tightly
regulated during ovulation so we only
see those peak and calcium transients
produced really at the onset of tissue
contraction additionally what I've shown
you is the actin network organization
coincides with contraction so it's all
stretch itself while required to
initiate contraction is insufficient to
align than network so it isn't just that
I've taken this isotropic network and
then pulled on it and that that is
what's causing the alignment instead
it's a very active process requires
myosin and then finally what I showed
you through multiple ways that my is an
activity it really appears to be finely
tuned such that if you have a smaller
fraction of a site that enters the
spermatheca you produce less contraction
you have a slightly less organized
Network if you go the other way and you
really ramp up the amount of active bias
and you then have really thick bundles
that are no longer orient in the proper
direction we think that's because myosin
is able to interact across multiple
actin bundles and really pull them in
two different directions and
appropriately I mean what I'm showing
you here on the bottom is just again if
you have either depressed or really
increased myosin activity you not only
alter actin organization
but you alter optimize a network
organization and myosin is now
differentially recruited to and
organized into these bundles okay and so
future work what are we interested in
doing next
well I focused so much today on acting
bison but really there are a lot of
other proteins interacting of actin so
actin participates in more protein
protein interactions than any other
protein themselves and we know that it's
not acting in isolation so we're now
interested in identifying other actin
interacting proteins they're influencing
things like the orientation of these
actin bundles and other actin tracking
proteins that are affecting their
connectivity so these were also be
important for determining the
contractile properties of this tissue
and one of the approaches we're taking
to do this is an RNA ice-cream so
another really great thing about working
with this animal is because they're
transparent they're really easy to
observe so what I'm showing you here is
the sperm a Pico expressing gfp and so
at the top here is a control animal and
there are two spermatheca lit up with
gfp one spermatheca appears very round
that's because this form adiga is
occupied by an oocyte whereas this other
spermatheca here appears very small and
compressed and that's because the
spermatheca is unoccupied and does not
have an O site present so in wild-type
animals these animals are constantly
ovulating each animal produces 300
offspring and so over time spermatheca
becomes occupied and then contracts and
occupied and contracts and contracts so
if we take a snapshot and look at a
whole population of animals we see that
a small fraction has an O site or an
embryo in the spermatheca
so it has that round and occupied
conformation whereas most of them are
unoccupied because they're constantly
contracting but we reasoned if we
disrupt a gene that's required for
contraction we should then see a shift
and now we should have a population that
has most of the oocytes or embryos
trapped in the spermatheca or if they're
not trapped at least spending a longer
time there because tissue contraction is
not initiated at the right point in time
so in this example I've shown you what
happens
get rid of PLC 1 PLC one is the
phospholipase C responsible for
producing those calcium transients that
then initiate contraction so we knew
that that gene would definitely disrupt
conjunction and that's what we use as a
control and if you look at the wild-type
side there are many worms and each
animal has most of them have unoccupied
spermatheca and then if you get rid of
plc one and we now have a population
where nearly every spermatheca or 100%
in this image are occupied so it's not
able to contract so we're now using
those to screen actin interacting genes
to identify ones that shift the
population so that more of the animals
haven't occupied from amigos so more
animals have a defect and contraction
alright and with that I would really
like to thank everybody who made this
word possible especially the grandma for
making a really wonderful place to work
and I'd like to make a special shout-out
to my advisor dr. Aaron Jake Ram has
been an excellent adviser and also to a
past graduate student is Marco vasilich
who made the initial observation that
the Acton organization of young animals
is different from the actual
organization and adults additionally
this work would not be possible without
our collaborators at the zidle Barr lab
who have just been great for bouncing
ideas off of and providing Wareham
strains additionally our funding and
other providers that worm strains from
the CGC and the Shearwood lab and that I
would like to take any questions
thank you dr. Alison Russian for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many of the
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is what is
the role of cell stretch and actin
organization that's a great question
because I know in other systems it's
been shown that if you increase cell
stretch you increase the production of
active bundles and in this case we do
think that some stretch is important but
not sufficient so cell stretch is really
important for triggering contraction and
we also have some data to suggest that
the degree of stall stretch correlates
with a degree of actin organization but
we think that's because cell stretch is
then increasing the amount of active
myosin it isn't just that as you stretch
this network more it becomes more
organized
thank you dr. Rocha the next question is
is there a way to increase or decrease
cell stretch yeah this is a question we
get asked all of the time especially by
people who work with really interesting
in vitro systems where they can grow
cells and different surfaces that allow
them to do things like compress the
cells and stretch the cells and poke
them with things one of the nice things
about having an in vivo system is that
we know that everything that's happening
happens for real in an unperturbed
system but one of the downsides is much
more difficult to manipulate so it's
hard for us to get in there and to do
things like stretch the spermatheca and
the absence of OS i entry to clearly
demonstrate that it's not something
special that a site is doing and more a
mechanical reaction to just being
stretched by this object and then
producing contraction one of the things
we have been able to do is to knock down
different genes that influence the size
of the site so that regulate OSI
streaming and produce a site that are
twice the size or smaller o sites and in
that case we do see that there is a
change in acting organization it's
somewhat subtle and it's very much like
the data that I showed you where when a
smaller piece of the OSI gets in there
it does not become as organized it's
more difficult for us to manage to get a
really large OHS ID in there it starts
the spermatheca outworn just because
those sites have a hard time entering in
those events are not very frequent
thank you for that answer the next
question is what are the actin bundles
attached to so that's something we're
actively pursuing typically you see
actin stress fibers ending in focal
adhesions and interacting with adhere
instructions so we know that focal
adhesion components are important in the
spermatheca but they do not produce
those really stereotypical really
prominent focal adhesions that you see
in adherent or laboratory cells
additionally we know that adherence
Junction components are important for
actin Network organization and
maintenance of the active network over
time so if you disrupt adhere
instructions you get disorganization of
the active network and it's also appears
to get worse over time suggesting that
they're important for actin organization
at MIT perhaps anchorage itself
interestingly however the adherence
Junction components are apical and these
actin bundles that we're looking at our
basal and they don't appear to come down
and touch the apical surface they don't
appear to be directly interacting and so
we have dumbness are in the eye screen
and have a few candidates very
interested in looking at to really find
out what is it that's connecting these
fibers to something potentially at the
apical side okay it looks like we have
time for one more question what are your
next steps
yes as I leave it to at the end of the
slide we've done this big RNA ice cream
to identify actin interacting proteins
that are important for organizing this
network so the the thing that I'm really
interested together is something that
would potentially influence actin
network connectivity or just connection
at the junctions so another actin
interacting protein that helps to
potentially cross-linked or bundle actin
filaments we've identified filament in a
previous screen and you're interested
dr. Kovac has a lot of work published on
that so that at least is one active
interacting gene that it plays an
important role but we're looking to
identify others I would like to once
again thank dr. Allison Wersching for
her presentation I would also like to
thank lab weights for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and hope to see you again soon
goodbye